I didn't sleep at all and I kept having
like when I was asleep I was like
dreaming about the pyramid and stuff
you're in it to win it Monica Aldama
you want Nefario college to bring home
the gold every single time they step
onto the mat and you've managed to do
just that
most of the time anyway when your
cheerleaders don't win first place you
push them four times as hard the
following year you record their every
move and strive for perfection and so
far it's working the 2020 NCAA college
nationals in Daytona will start in April
and you've got us wondering if Netflix
will cover the event and release a
second season of cheer so tell us Monica
is Netflix secretly filming as we speak
Netflix is six-part documentary at a
time fans want to see more of their
favorite Navaro college cheerleaders and
their intensely driven coach Monica of
course watch until the end to find out
what season two of cheer will be about
and whether or not the rumors are true
but before we reveal all the details
we'd like to remind you that this video
contains spoilers so continue watching
at your discretion the last episode of
Netflix's cheer was both emotional and
exhilarating at the same time although
they performed a flawless routine for
the judges it didn't come scot free
Austin Bale so tumblr who took part in
the first performance was badly injured
and rushed off the mat but the team got
a chance at redemption and came out on
top
under Monica Thomas iron grip the dogs
won the national championship for the
14th time in 2019 but for many of the
team members this was their last year
competing in Daytona
cheerleading legend Gabi Butler has
since left Navarro choosing to pursue
new opportunities and the same goes for
Austin bales and Mackenzie Sherbourne
who are now cheering at Texas Tech
University but a handful of the original
team members from Netflix's cheer have
decided to return to navarro for a
second or third year the last episode of
cheer had fans in dismay when news of
Lexi Brownback's expulsion came out but
it looks like the master tumbler has
been given a second chance which beckons
the question will we get to see Monica
and her team take home
our 15th victory in 2020 or was the
docu-series a one-time thing well as it
turns out there might be one thing
standing in their way the NCAA an NDA
rulebook we have a legacy - a pole if
you don't want to be here there's the
door Netflix's cheer brought many issues
to light and we're not only talking
about the sports dangerous background
we're talking about varsity the global
authority of competitive cheerleading
and how restrictive their rules can be
despite the nature of the documentary
the filming crew was not granted access
to film the NCAA college nationals
competition
luckily director Greg Whitely had the
idea to collect amateur footage from the
events many spectators although fans of
the docu-series are waiting for season
two of cheer to get the green light
things might not be that simple the
competition rulebook clearly states that
teams may jeopardize their eligibility
to compete if they participate in a
televised program or print media that
portrays their team school or general
activity in a negative manner so now
that the cheer cat is out of the bag the
NCAA must deem it appropriate before a
second season is approved the last thing
Navarro wants is to get banned from
competing so talk of season two is being
kept under wraps while some aspects of
Netflix's cheer can be portrayed
negatively the docu-series advertises
the complexity of the sport instead of
tearing it down so who knows a second
season could be underway but that
doesn't necessarily mean that season two
would focus on Monica and her Navarro
cheerleaders
[Music]
this isn't Gregg Whiteley's first time
divulging the ins and outs of
competitive sports Gregg first created
last chance you in 2016 this docu-series
follows a team of community college
football players the popular show has
gone on to have four seasons and the
very same thing could happen with cheer
but there's one thing we should keep in
mind especially if we're using last
chance you as a reference of what's to
come
season two could potentially follow
another college cheer squad as they prep
for the Daytona championship instead of
continuing with Monica and the dogs but
if this theory does indeed become a
reality which team would Greg Whitely
choose to follow well the answer could
have been staring us in the face since
the very beginning the only other team
in the co-ed gr Junior College division
is none other than Trinity Valley
Vontae Johnson is the Trinity Valley
Community College cheer coach and he's
known as Monica's number one rival
Netflix could show the errs the other
side of the coin by featuring vantes
team in season two doing this would help
balance things out and if you think
about it this theory isn't too
far-fetched after all we did briefly
encounter Vontae Johnson in season one I
got one goal to be the best in the whole
entire world in a perfect world Netflix
would announce that cheer is returning
for a second season which will follow
Navarro College as they compete for the
2020 NCAA Championships in Daytona we'd
love to see some of our favorites
returned to the small screen but since
many of them have parted ways with
Monica a batch of new faces could be in
the works after all we did see Monica
hosting tryouts for the following
semester at the end of the docq series
this could prove that Netflix has
already signed a deal with the college
solidifying a second season however
things seem to be on a need-to-know
basis for the time being
cheer sweethearts like Jerry Harris
ladarius Marshall Morgan Simeon ER and
Lexie Brumback are back at Navarro
prepping for the championships with
Monica the Daytona competition will be
held in mid-april and there's just no
way of knowing if Greg white Lee and his
crew will be covering the event whatever
the case might be we're happy to know
that Lexie has been welcomed
act in a barrio college and let's just
say that Netflix has been dropping hints
about her on Instagram Netflix has been
posting about the cheer squad
ever since the docu-series first aired
is this their way of promoting a second
season or are they just filling us in on
what's going on keep watching to find
out which major clue points toward their
being a season 2 Morgan and that's
slower than yesterday when asked about
the possibility of season 2 Monica
remained tight-lipped about the whole
ordeal according to the legendary cheer
coach she doesn't know anything about a
season two at the moment instead she's
just really excited about season 1 and
how it was just released but Monica may
have signed a contract preventing her
from revealing Netflix's plans after all
it has been revealed that varsity is in
talks with the Netflix so the
possibility of future installments is
substantial TMZ reported that there have
been discussions for varsity and Netflix
to work together again in the future
which offers fans a sliver of hope in
the meantime Monica is determined to
stay focused on what matters
winning the NCAA national championship
for the 15th time varsity denied Greg
white Lee and his crew the right to film
the Daytona Championships and while many
believe this is due to varsity wanting
to be the sole provider of the event
this isn't exactly the case according to
decider the NCAA and the NBA have
recently changed their code of conduct
rules preventing cheer teams from
getting a leg up in the competition the
rules were reportedly altered when
Netflix's chair made its grand debut on
the streaming service they've won the
Grand Championship several times they
could beat anybody they believe that the
docu-series might have brought too much
hype to the competition which could get
in the way of fair ruling they also
believe that allowing a large camera
crew to film the competition could add
additional stress to competitors
deferring them from their goals but
Monica is adamant about being frugal
with what we hear on mainstream media I
don't want you leaving the mat or the
side of the mat
the intense world of competitive
cheerleading has recently made headlines
and people are hooked with so much hype
surrounding the sport it's only normal
that Netflix would want to ride out the
trend however if they aren't permitted
to continue shooting cheer other
networks could take advantage of the
sports popularity so what if networks
like lifetime or TLC decided to create a
spin-off series for junior cheerleaders
the show could follow a similar template
as Dance Moms
we all know how invested cheer parents
can be just ask Gabby Butler we don't
know about you but we'd love for a
reality TV show called cheer moms to
make headlines sometime soon
while sites like decider are quick to
mention that the cheerleading rulebook
has been altered in spite of the Netflix
series the Navaro coach Warren's fans
about buying into these publications
Monica Aldama took to Facebook to reveal
that no rules have been changed and that
everything is the same as last year
she has adamantly stated that varsity
has always been supportive of Netflix's
cheer so in other words she's basically
stating that there is no conflict
between varsity and Netflix which was
one of the only things standing in
season two's way if starring in yet
another season of cheer won't prevent
the dogs from competing what's standing
in their way from accepting a recurring
role nothing that's what you know those
are my kids
I'll fight tooth and nail for them but
perhaps the biggest clue that season two
of cheer will soon be available on
Netflix was revealed during an interview
with Entertainment Tonight
Lexi Jerry and Gabby were asked whether
or not a camera crew had been following
the dogs around and instead of giving a
straightforward answer the cheers stars
immediately changed the subject as if
they were instructed to do just that not
wanting to talk about a second season
and refusing to reveal if they're being
filmed is pretty suspicious after all if
they were being filmed wouldn't they
just say no come on dogs just throw us a
bone here hopes are high for season two
of cheer and with the docu-series recent
success it would be a shame to put an
end to the franchise if Greg Whitely
managed to turn last chance u into a
multi season series this
could very well happen to cheer if
season two of cheer receives the green
light would you want it to follow
Navarro college or a Trinity Valley tell
us in the comments for more videos like
this one subscribe to the things and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up while you're at it we'll see
you next time
thanks for watching